un acuerdo en vilo y cientos de
toneladas de granos ucranianos siendo
transportadas al exterior a través del
corredor humanitario del mar Negro
después de que el sábado Moscú
suspendiera el pacto por supuestos
ataques ucranianos contra su flotan
crimea ya que según Rusia estaría usando
el corredor con fines militares algo que
desmintió Naciones Unidas este lunes
señalando que no había tránsito a través
del corredor humanitario la noche del 29
de octubre el kremlin habla de falta de
garantías de seguridad
Cuando Rusia habla de que es imposible
garantizar el paso seguro de los barcos
en estas áreas este tipo de acuerdo es
por supuesto apenas factible y adquiere
un carácter diferente uno mucho más
arriesgado más peligroso y sin garantías
aparte
Turquía uno de los garantes del acuerdo
firmado el pasado agosto mantuvo
conversaciones telefónicas con el
Ministerio de defensa ruso para que
moscurre evalúe su decisión de retirarse
apelando a la importancia de continuar
como algo ajeno al conflicto de Ucrania
durante la reunión con el ministro acaar
se Indicó que se espera reconsiderar la
decisión de suspender la iniciativa de
envío de granos que debe ser separada de
las condiciones del conflicto y que es
una actividad puramente humanitaria tras
la llamada al kremlin señaló que es
inaceptable que los envíos pasaran por
el corredor en su previa inspección
mientras que kiev prometió continuar con
las exportaciones
Rusia está haciendo todo lo posible para
que al menos cientos de miles de estas
personas se conviertan en migrantes
forzados que buscarán asilo en Turquía o
en países de la Unión Europea o morirán
de hambre y debemos junto a nuestros
socios hacer todo lo posible para que la
iniciativa de los cereales sino que
funcione al 100% de su capacidad
la aseguradora de Lloyd of London
declaró que suspenderá la suscripción de
cobertura para nuevos de envíos que
utilicen el corredor de granos
ucranianos en el mar Negro hasta que se
tenga más claridad en medio de una
disputa que está generando una crisis
alimentaria mundial